[Music]
there's nobody remotely like you you're
one of a kind there's just one Jeff
Goldblum in the world and he's right
here antastic but you are too that's why
I call you snowflake because oh because
no two are alike yes you get that right
away no no no well I also I melt quickly
in the heat so I like this sort of
gentleman greaser look I know that is a
fetching jacket I have to say really
yeah but I would fit you one way to find
out let's try it on
[Music]
let's try the Sun Oh your sound mic is
on I don't care we're gonna be attached
by a sound car cord momentarily look at
that
what the Mike I gotta have this jacket
now I've got a what's that oh yeah it's
right there okay come on and I think it
goes there we go
what is also II I'm also in that Union
tell you no it's just fantastic my whole
attitude changes when look at that
jacket fits you quite well we're like
the same guy that's right only I'm like
a tough guy well the sleeves are a
problem that is borrowing from your
Bernie Sanders in person this is tough
pretty soon you look fantastic now we
have a lot to talk about and then we'll
take our other clothes off later
you